الصراع بين اكبر اقتصادين في العالم قاد
صندوق النقد الدولي للتحذير من تداعيات
التنافس الامريكي الصيني على الاقتصاد
العالمي مديره صندوق النقد الدولي
كريستالينا جورجيافا قالت ان الرسوم
الجمركيه التي فرضها الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب على الواردات الصينيه
بدات تاتي بنتائج عكسيه ومنذ اشهر تحاول
الاداره الامريكيه تخفيفه تكاليف رسوم
المفروضه على الواردات الصينيه بالتزامن
مع جهود كبح التضخم كما تعلمون الا ان
المناورات العسكريه التي تجريها الصين حول
تايوان دفعت مسؤولي اداره
التفكير بشان الغاء بعض الرسوم او اعاده
فرض الرسوم اخرى على البكيني
حتى الان لم يحل الرئيس جو بايدن بعد
القضيه الرئيسه المتعلقه بالرسوم الجمركيه
التي فرضها سلفه على بضائع صينيه وكلفت
المستوردين الامريكيين مليارات دولارات
نعود مجددا لمديره صندوق النقد الدولي
كريستالي جورجيا التي قالت لواشنطن بوست
انها كمواطن بلغاريا عاشت الحرب البارده
واعتبرت ان اقتحام جيل جديد في حرب بارده
ثانيه امر غير مسؤول على الاطلاق
[موسيقى]